okay this is a candy crush soda saga
level 112 walkthrough with some added
commentary I made this video a little
bit earlier and forgot to hit the record
button so I'm adding the audit audio up
afterwards reason I made the video today
was because they added ten more moves to
the level and if you if you you know if
you're in our group or you subscribe to
our channel you probably seen the video
that we made which you know explains how
to get the Bears to get the cold the
bear low and bring the bottles up from
the bottom and someone had posted a
couple people actually had posted that
it wasn't working anymore so I checked
it out and it does in fact still work so
I wanted to make this video to explain
it in a little more detail how do you do
it the key is to keep the bear low on
the board so that you can keep the
scroll at this point at this level where
you don't see the top half right where
the yellow candy is here if you don't
want the bear to move above that so when
you get that set up you have to free the
extra bottle that's inside there there's
two of them that are in the coming that
you have to get out first and once you
do new bottles will rise to the top
right away so what I'm trying to do here
is I'm just trying to free this bottle
without having the bear move above where
that green candy in the middle is right
now so you can see I used the striped
candy there to hit it but he only moved
up one place so it's okay and he can
still move one more and we won't run
into any problems so the coloring
candies free over there now there's no
orange pieces in front of the bear as
you can see so we can use that to free
up the last we can
turn the orange to green and then we can
work on trying to get the last bottle
free from the honey we couldn't really
do the red because that would cost
things to move down and with the extra
ten moves that they added you can be you
can take your time a little bit we don't
want to it's more important to be
careful about the bear than it is to
move really fast of course you could
also run out of moves freeing the bear
isn't go bringing the bottles up isn't
gonna guarantee that you're gonna finish
it but it'll get you going in the right
direction and so you just need to keep
them there or you can move up one more
row but you don't want him to move any
higher than that because as soon as he
does you won't be able to actually bring
in bottles up anymore so there's our
last bottle and watch as soon as it pops
everyone comes from the bottom see that
he's still where we need him to be so we
just want to bring at this point we just
want to bring bought more bottles up so
we can get enough of them pop before so
that the seller will fill up the top
half before we move them up see as soon
as one pops the next one appears so like
here you know we couldn't match these
green up there to make a stripe because
they would move them too high but as
long as we're careful we just don't make
any matches in front of the bear we'll
be able to hold him where is that and
get a couple more bottles to pop I
didn't count the bottles when I was
playing but um you might want to pay
attention to that see where you need to
be before when this level had less moves
it was you know my rule of thumb was to
wait till I had about 10 moves left
before I moved up but now since you can
see here we have like 23 that's not as
big of a thing as it used to be
so you know you can you could still go
by that but in most cases you'll
probably be able to pop quite a few and
before that and you won't have to worry
about it
so there's another one as you can see
one pops in its place and so this will
keep doing this as long as you need at
this point we've probably talked enough
of them so technically this is gonna
move it up at least one some more models
might show up but the main problem is
that those holes at the top of the board
will be blocking the but you know for
blocking the pieces from moving up
easily so at that point once you move
them a little bit further you're gonna
want to change yours to get one more
bottle cane but when we pop that one we
don't really see any more right away so
at this point you want to shift your
your your focus to moving up on the
board
so when he moves there you can see one
more bottle came up but it's gonna be
hard to get to and you know definitely
pop it if you see it there but keep in
mind how many moves you have now because
we're down to 12 and the Minnesota is
likely already at the top of the board
based on how many we pop so it you know
pop that bottle if you can but instead
start looking up and just making matches
above the bear and you see yeah the soda
is all the way up so all we needs to do
at this point is to match them that's
that now we just need to get a striped
candy or something behind the bear to
move them all the way the fish won't
help on this they'll go after the
bottles and the honey you know you
probably know that for me nor our honey
guide it's one of the things that's
really cool about the honey boards
compared to the ice or the frosting
levels but it won't help us here so you
can see I've just made a striped I can
fire that up the bear gets to the top
and that's how you do it
so I hope that helps I mean I'm gonna I
made this to go along with the guy that
I'll write to all the tips out on our
site candy crush saga tips calm and you
know I'll go into a little more detail
there but that's the general thing if
the bear gets above that spot at the
bottom I generally just hit the quit
button at that point and start over
because I know it's not going to it's
not gonna be real easy to get the bear
all the way to the top it is possible
and it have done that since the add the
10 extra moves moved it through the top
without bringing the bottles up but you
have to really you have to clear out all
the honey on the top bring the bear up
and then they'll start to fall from the
top so it's really not a great strategy
I don't think so hope this helps please
like the video if you found it helpful
check the comment a check the
description to find our links all of our
stuff our group on Facebook our website
and
we'll be making more videos soon so just
leave a comment if you need help with
something and we'll try to help you out
thanks